m
la réunion a inauguré la première
conférence des financeurs de la
prévention de la perte d'autonomie des
personnes âgées
cette séquence s'est déroulée le 18
novembre dans l'hémicycle du palais de
la source
sous la présidence du département de la
rs océan indien et du j'ai eu le
vieillissement actif en assurant la vice
présidence
la conférence des financeurs a pour
objectif de coordonner les différents
acteurs et leurs actions le but étant
d'améliorer l'offre et la lisibilité des
dispositifs de prévention de la perte
d'autonomie destinés aux personnes âgées
de 60 ans et plus
l'idée c'était de poser à la fois la
gouvernance de cette conférence qui sera
mené par une un comité exécutif composé
donc du département de l' agence
régionale de santé mais également du
groupement d'intérêt économique
vieillissement actif portées par les
trois caisses de retraite de la sécurité
sociale et une seconde instance donc la
conférence des financeurs qui donc
l'assemblée plénière de cette de cette
conférence qui portera en fait le
programme coordonné des actions de
prévention et de la perte d'autonomie
des personnes âgées sur le département
de la réunion
nous avons eu une enveloppe de cas un
peu plus plus de 93 mille euros pour
mener à la fois cette ingénierie donc
diagnostic de territoire et première
action prévention qui seront mises en
oeuvre sur le territoire en faveur des
personnes âgées mais également des
aidants familiaux à compter de 2016 nous
attendons une enveloppe qui sera au
prorata du nombre de personnes âgées sur
le territoire qui permettra de financer
d'autres actions de prévention
d'expérimentation de spasad et un
forfait autonomie au sein des
établissements
accueillant des personnes âgées